Hallo, Stefan.
Wie ist es?
Ja, mir geht's ganz gut, ich mein...
Wolltest du mir gerade eine Eingangsfrage stellen?
Ja, ich wollte eine Eingangsfrage stellen. Ich muss sie dir stellen, denn ich habe bei Instagram dich gesehen. Da warst du auf einem Fahrgeschäft, wie man früher sagte, auf einer, ich glaube, Würmchenbahn hieß die. Wo warst du? Warst du im Phantasialand oder was?
Ja, wir haben unangekündigt im Podcast gestern den ersten Taron-Tag im Corona-Zeitalter gemacht. Ich war also gestern Taron-Fahren und ich habe, da ich nicht viel gefilmt habe, nur eine Taron-Fahrt, wo ich erste Reihe, ich durfte gestern zwei Mal erste Reihe fahren, war nicht viel los. Und dann habe ich das kombiniert mit so einem Würmchen-Express, denn so nach, wenn es Phantasialand leer ist, kann man viel machen und dann ist man aber relativ, irgendwann dann auch KO so 14, 15 Uhr. Also habe ich gesagt, komm, wir fahren jetzt alle mal Würmchen-Express. Und dann habe ich meinen eigenen Corona-Bedingten, meinen eigenen kleinen Würmchen-Express-Shuttle bekommen. Und dann habe ich das so ein bisschen kombiniert.
Und was ist Taron-Bahn?
Der Taron ist eine Achterbahn eingebettet in die Erlebniswelt Klugheim. Das kann man im Video gut sehen. Das ist so eine Mittelalter, Mittelerde, Stein irgendwie und so weiter. Kleines Dörfchen, altes Holz und so. Und da fährt eine Achterbahn mit der schnellsten Magnetabschussstrecke der Welt. Allerdings nicht schon beim Start, sondern man fährt schon ungefähr 60-70 kmh, rauscht dann ganz unten auf den niedrigsten Punkt in einen Keller, wird nochmal auf 117 beschleunigt, um dann sofort 30 Meter Höhe gut zu machen. Also man ist kurz ganz schnell und bremst dann 30 Meter Höhenmeter wieder ab und fährt dann mit 80, 70, 60 kmh den Bogen zu Ende. Es ist eine super lange Achterbahn, über 1 Kilometer und sie kreuzt sich 116 Mal selbst. Also sehr in sich verschlungen und trotzdem immer wieder meine Empfehlung, die zu fahren, denn kein Looping, keine Überschläge, nichts. Man ist nicht mit einem Schultergurt oder sonst wie die Beine baumeln frei. Man sitzt einfach nur und hat auf seinem Schoß ein kleines Ding, das einen hält, super sicher. Also es ist die Achterbahn, auf der man sich am freiesten fühlt und die den Körper am besten respektiert, die dich nicht in irgendwelche übernatürlichen Füße in den Himmel und so weiter, irgendwelche blöden Loopings und so, sondern du kommst einfach aus der Bahn, deine Beine sind ein bisschen wackelig, aber dir ist nicht schlecht. Es ist einfach ein spektakuläres Erleben für eine Minute und zehn Sekunden.
Interessant.
Du solltest mal mitkommen, würde ich sagen.
Ja, ich glaube auch, ich merke vor allem, dass ich sehr lange nicht im Phantasialand war. Genau, das ist ein Brühl, da ist man in 50 Minuten und ich war da natürlich früher auch öfter und wahrscheinlich hat sich da sehr viel verändert. Gibt es die Silbermine noch, frage ich da gleich?
Je nachdem, was du mit Silbermine meinst, es gibt Colorado Express, also immer noch diesen Colorado.
Nein, so eine ganz langsame Fahrt. Ich bin natürlich da ganz anders. Ich möchte so eine schöne, ruhige Fahrt durch so eine Westernstadt war das. Vielleicht gibt es das aber nicht mehr.
Ja, also es gibt noch den Colorado Express, ob das jetzt Westernstadt ist, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Es ist immer ein bisschen so. Ich bin 2017, 2018 oder so haben wir den ersten Tag und Tag gemacht. Und dann machen wir es zweimal im Jahr immer. Und das Phantasialand ist flächenmäßig relativ klein, was immer bedeutet, wenn eine Attraktion neu geplant und aufgebaut wird, muss eine andere dafür weichen. Anders als im Europa-Park oder so in anderen Freizeitparks, weil die Stadt Brühl ist da sehr restriktiv. Das finde ich macht aber den Park super interessant, weil die einfach jeden Quadratmeter nutzen. Also da fährt man nicht einfach Achterbahn auf einer Schiene, sondern alles, was du siehst, während du fährst, ist einfach Klugheim. Du bist dann wirklich in so einer anderen Welt. Das sieht man ja in dem Video glaube ich ganz gut, dass man da einfach, man fährt da nicht neben dem Stromkasten vorbei oder so. Die machen sich da Gedanken, was für Pflanzen, Musik und so weiter. Also es ist so ein kompletter Erlebnis. Eigentlich das Metaverse Offline. Das, was ich Mark Zuckerberg wünscht, ist dort real mit echten Menschen, nicht nur mit Avatar. Und ich kenne aber das Phantasialand nicht von vor vier Jahren. Also alles, was jemals abgebaut wurde. Es kommen ja ganz viele aus der Region, die mir dann immer sagen, ja hier und da und so. Und dann denke ich mal, ja gut, ihr wart vor 30, 20 Jahren hier im Phantasialand. Da war das irgendwie eine andere Welt. Jetzt gibt es halt noch die Geister-Rikscha. Das ist so eine Hinterlassenschaft. Da sieht man aber auch, da geht man so ganz ironisch noch mal rein und macht so 5 Minuten Pause und guckt sich an, was man vor 40 Jahren gruselig fand oder so. Also in deren Sicht, ich kenne nur das aktuelle Phantasialand. Es gibt immer noch dieses Wildwesten, natürlich diese Colorado-Achterbahn, die ja Michael Jackson damals eröffnet hat. Und die ist auch sehr wackelig. Man fühlt sich da auch ein bisschen holprig. Und man merkt, das ist alte Technik. Aber man kann dann in den Taron einsteigen. Das ist ein Gleiten durch Gluckheim.
Interessant. Und das heißt, du kannst dich jetzt da so aus unserer realpolitischen Welt ausklinken und hast gar keine Sorgen, dass man jetzt in Berlin irgendwas macht und du das nicht mitbekommst?
Ich will noch mal aufgreifen. Wir haben das ja am letzten Mal schon kurz angesprochen. Es ist Wahltag und du stellst fest, viele Leute laufen hier Marathon und kümmern sich gar nicht darum, was wenige Kilometer entfernt im Regierungsviertel passiert. Da gab es natürlich einige Kommentare zu, hinsichtlich muss der Wolfgang immer so arrogant über die Sportler sein und das sei natürlich zugestanden, aber ich merke an mir, wie ich jetzt selbst in diesen Zustand reinrutsche, dass ich irgendwie Robert Habeck, Annalena Baerbock, Lindner, Joachim Vogel oder wie er heißt sehe, irgendwann kommt dann Lars Klingbeil ins Bild hinzu, Olaf Scholz hält sich zurück und denkt mir, warum nicht, das können die jetzt von mir ein paar Wochen so machen, bis sie ihre Koalition geschmiedet haben und danach von mir aus ein paar Jahre, bis halt eine Neuwahl ansteht.
Das heißt, du willst nicht gestört werden?
Also erstmals nach vielen Jahren, in denen Peter Altmaier die Geschäfte des Wirtschaftsministeriums führt oder Scheuer und die CSU, das Verkehrsministerium, denke ich mir so ein bisschen, die kann man auch machen lassen. Man sieht ja gerade, der Spiegel hat ja einen großen Text dazu gemacht, den hat dann über Medien reflektiert, sehr kritisch, dass gerade nichts zu hören und nichts zu berichten ist. Und Journalisten leiden darunter. Und ich denke mir, das ist ein guter Indikator für einen Zustand der politischen Welt in Deutschland, über den wir sehr zufrieden sein müssen. Wer politisches Spektakel will, der kann jetzt gerade mal nach England gucken oder nach Österreich und sich dann überlegen, will ich das hier auch oder akzeptiere ich den Zustand, wie er gerade ist. Und ich finde, wir sind hier so ein bisschen, wir sollten uns alle mal nicht beschweren. Es läuft super gerade. Ich bin wahnsinnig entspannt. Allerdings habe ich auch keine Sorgen, beispielsweise so einen wöchentlichen Fernsehpodcast zu füllen, weil ich genau weiß, es gibt ja noch genug Themen. Ich muss mich ja nicht am letzten Zitat von wem auch immer aufhängen und ehrlich gesagt, die CDU-Zitate, die gerade fallen, die sind mir mal total Schnurze egal, also die lasse ich einfach nix liegen. Und in der Ansicht finde ich, ist das gerade eine ganz entspannte, völlig aus der Zeit gefallene Situation, in der wir hier in Deutschland gerade sind.
Ja, für mich ist ja sowieso das Tagespolitische nicht so interessant. Ich verfolge das eigentlich kaum, sehe ja wenig Nachrichten, höchstens schaue ich mir mal im Nachhinein noch was bei YouTube an und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass ich Tageszeitungen lese, um zu wissen, was hat jetzt Minister XY gesagt. Das hat mich ja noch nie beschäftigt oder ich habe auch nie diese großen Politiker-Porträts gelesen. Insofern ist es für mich jetzt eigentlich wie immer, ich bekomme das so am Rande mit, diese ganz großen Ereignisse, wenn es dann mal eins gibt, finden ja dann bei Twitter auch sofort statt. Da hat man nur Twitter geöffnet und schon hat man es gelesen und sonst gehe ich auch so den Dingen nach, die mich eigentlich interessieren oder man entdeckt etwas. Ich habe zum Beispiel etwas entdeckt. Tony Bennett, dieser große Sänger inzwischen 95 Jahre alt, hat ja mit Lady Gaga noch mal ein Album aufgenommen. Das haben sie schon mal vor ein paar Jahren gemacht, so ein Swing-Album. Ich fand das ziemlich schrecklich und sie sind dann auch live damit aufgetreten und das hatte alles nicht so gut gepasst. Ich fand auch die Arrangements eigentlich fürchterlich und fand auch, dass diese beiden Stimmen dann vielleicht gar nicht so gut zusammenpassten. Das hat sich jetzt nicht fundamental bei mir geändert, diese Auffassung, was aber hochinteressant ist, auch mit Blick auf Altern, auf Krankheit und all das ist, dass man jetzt erfuhr, dass Tony Bennett seit einigen Jahren Alzheimerkranke ist und dass er aber, wenn er Musik macht, noch wahnsinnig gut funktioniert und nicht nur, dass er was abruft, was immer schon da war, sondern dass er, wenn man ihm etwas vorspielt und er dann zu singen beginnt, auch neu frasiert, dass er also tatsächlich noch mal etwas Neues kreiert. Und es gab eine Sendung, Sixty Minutes, die kann man auch bei YouTube sich ansehen, die ihn dann begleitet hat und auch Lady Gaga und es war so, dass jetzt er 95 wurde und er noch ein Abschiedskonzert geben sollte. Und das ist ganz berührend zu sehen, weil Lady Gaga dann erzählt, sie haben dann geprobt und ja auch das Album eingesungen, aber so in den letzten Monaten hatte er wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gewusst, wer sie ist. Also er hat dann immer gesagt, my darling und so, aber eigentlich war nicht mehr klar, was kriegt er eigentlich jetzt davon mit und dann sind sie auch in der Garderobe, seine Frau und er, die Frau ist wesentlich jünger und sagt ihm dann, jetzt ist gleich dein Auftritt und so und er fragt dann auch, was soll ich denn singen und er sieht dann Lady Gaga da auf der Bühne und kann damit aber auch eigentlich nichts anfangen und dann wird er auf die Bühne geführt, der Vorhang geht auf, ist ein großer Saal, wirklich mit sehr vielen Menschen dort und du hast in dem Moment plötzlich keine Spur mehr von Alzheimer. Er begrüßt das Publikum, wie er das immer gemacht hat. Er singt, hat wohl ein paar kleine Texthänger mal, wird dann gesagt, kann man das sehen, aber sonst ist es beeindruckend, auch bestimmtlich ziemlich stark, was er dann da abliefert und dann bittet er Lady Gaga auf die Bühne, also sie kommt auf die Bühne und er sieht sie und sagt Lady Gaga und sie ist total überrascht, dass plötzlich sogar ihr Name wieder ihm einfällt und dann singen sie ein wunderbares Duett zusammen und zwei Tage später weiß er natürlich nicht mehr, dass er das Konzert gegeben hat, aber es ist so interessant zu sehen, dass dann trotz Alzheimer mit der Musik plötzlich eine andere Seinsweise noch mal möglich ist, bei der man nicht sagen kann, naja, der wird jetzt dazu gezwungen aufzutreten oder der ruft einfach nur was aus der Erinnerung ab, sondern irgendwas entsteht er auch Ja, das ist ja auch eine Weise zu existieren. Also es ist sehr interessant, eigentlich schon fast ein philosophisches Thema. Was ist das eigentlich dann für ein Bewusstsein? Wo ist er denn der echte Tony Bennett? Dann, wenn er da mit Alzheimer sitzt und nicht genau weiß, wer ist da eigentlich, was kommt jetzt als nächstes? Oder wenn er da auf der Bühne kraftvoll steht, singt und seine Lieder schmettert?
Also Musik hat ja sowieso ihre eigene Magie, das ist ja immer so ein beliebter Satz. Es sind natürlich besondere Herausforderungen jetzt noch mal hinsichtlich der Überlegung zu Kunst und Künstler, wie weit man das trennen muss. Also kann man sich noch, wie soll man sagen, kann man es noch mit Genuss anschauen, wenn man eigentlich die medizinischen Hintergründe kennt und so. Auf der anderen Seite ist ja echt eine Überlegung, inwieweit, wir wissen ja, Alzheimer kommt ja auch mal so in Schüben. Berichten ja dann die Pfleger immer, es gibt so gute Tage, schlechte Tage irgendwie, es wechselt sich ab. Ob man das über Musik steuern kann, denn Alzheimer und dann auch Hinblick auf Erinnerungen und so, da hat man es ja mit der Herausforderung zu tun, Erinnerungen so tief zu verankern, dass sie wirklich abrufbar sind. Also Alzheimer-Patienten, die dann plötzlich 60 Jahre alte Erinnerungen als gerade passiert, bin ich gerade mittendrin, erlebe ich gerade noch mal und so weiter durchspielen. Und mir ist es jetzt wieder aufgefallen, als wir einen fünfjährigen Geburtstag gefeiert haben in meiner Familie. Also 90 Jahre Differenz zwischen deiner Story und meiner. Wie sehr sich Kinder freuen, und man sieht das dann so an so einem verschämten Lächeln, wenn man merkt, es freuen sie sich wirklich, aber wollen es auch nicht so richtig zeigen, wenn man sie fragt, was soll man denn jetzt für dich singen? Und dann suchen sie sich ihr Lied aus und dann singt man es auch. Und dann sitzen sie so da und freuen sich halt darüber, dass das so Momente sind, in denen man solche ganz tiefen Erinnerungen pflanzt, an die man dann einfach anknüpfen kann 70, 80, 90 Jahre später. Also in der Ansicht scheint Gesang noch mal eine Methode und ein Mittel zu sein, bei dem man auch im Publikum, glaube ich, noch mal zeigen kann, was Musik eigentlich bedeutet. Also nicht nur Kunst und Künstler, sondern das Medium der Musik überhaupt an sich einfach mal so jetzt in diesem Rahmen präsentieren. Da wird es dann noch mal offenbar. Also in der Ansicht, ja aber krass 95 Jahre, das ist dringend der Empfehlung, sich das mal anzusehen bei YouTube.
Da gibt es wirklich bei 60 Minutes einen ganz interessanten Bericht über dieses Konzert und wie die beiden auch zusammengearbeitet haben und wie eng diese Verbindung war. Und wir werden aber ja heute sehr realwirtschaftlich.
Genau, lassen wir uns kurz, apropos 60 Minutes, wir haben über die Facebook-Files gesprochen. Jetzt sind sie schon veröffentlicht über Wall Street Journal direkt, das konnten wir noch vermelden. Als wir darüber sprachen, hat Facebook selbst eine kommentierte Version in voller Länge veröffentlicht, also um noch irgendwas einzufangen, was man auch vorher schon mal einfangen könnte. Dann am Tage, also am amerikanischen Tage, nachdem wir aufgenommen hatten, war das im Kongress-Thema und jetzt am Wochenende war in 60 Minutes die Wisselblowerin, sozusagen, hat sich dann selbst nochmal so gestellt im Fernsehen, dass man ihre Aussagen gegen frühere Aussagen von Mark Zuckerberg so querschneiden konnte, dass da auch tolle Twitter-Videos kurz entstanden sind, gerade Instagram beschäftigt die Leute unglaublich, alles andere ist so ein bisschen okay, aber diese Instagram Körperbilder, Teens und so weiter, das scheint doch ein mega Thema zu sein.
Ja und wir hatten ja ein Facebook und Instagram Down, das war ja auch mal für sechs Stunden und man hat gesehen, es geht auch ohne, die Welt drehte sich weiter und vielleicht haben die Leute sogar in diesen sechs Stunden was Nünftiges gemacht, für Influencer sicherlich eine harte Zeit, aber man kann daran vielleicht ganz gut sehen, was braucht man da wirklich von und was könnte man zerschlagen oder zumindest so regulieren, dass da vieles nicht mehr möglich ist. Also hast du denn jetzt die Hoffnung, dass wo das noch mal so schwarz auf weiß ja wirklich da steht, dass das noch mal etwas bewirkt oder ist das jetzt diese Aufreger, den wir haben und Tech-Journalisten setzen sich noch mal tiefer damit auseinander und jetzt hat man noch mal ganz klar es vor Augen, was da eigentlich passiert, aber politisch wird sich nichts ändern.
Also wir haben auf der einen Seite so einen ganz sichtbaren Too-Big-Too-Fail-Zionismus, der sich vor allem unter Journalisten breitmacht, die dann auf Twitter schreiben. Meistens sind das dann immer so angehängte Bilder vom Kurs und dann sind immer so Pfeile von oben in den Aktienkurs. Der letzten fünf Jahre Facebook markiert, was weiß ich, hier Cambridge Analytica, hier das und hier jenes. Da sieht man immer, danach ging es immer hoch. Und darunter läuft immer die Annahme, dass nur die öffentliche Meinung Facebook bezwingen kann. Und ich glaube, das ändert sich gerade. Denn den Juristen, sowohl die im Kongress zuarbeiten machen für Gesetzestexte, die da entstehen, als auch die Juristen, die tatsächlich nochmal abseits der Politik in der Juristerei tatsächlich über das Schicksal Facebooks befinden, denen ist öffentliche Meinung manchmal ein bisschen egal. Und ich glaube, da ist doch einiges in Bewegung. Und Sheryl Sandberg abschiedet sich tatsächlich so langsam von Facebook. Also es ist ganz merkwürdig so zu sehen. Klar, wir kriegen erst in zwei Jahren wieder diese Bücher, an denen das dann so nacherzählt wird, wie das so war, als dann Mark Zuckerberg die Zügel angezogen hat und so. Aber wir haben es ja mit Mark Zuckerberg mittlerweile mit einem anzynismusstrotzenden Personen zu tun, die wirklich über den Dingen schweben möchte, dass da glaube ich ganz groher Handlungsdruck entsteht und auch schon sichtbar ist. Also wir wissen ja auch, wie die Agenturen, die sich politisch da gerade mit befassen, besetzt sind von beiden. Also das sind ja wirklich die harten Hunde oder Hündinnen, sind ja auch viele Frauen, die da jetzt so richtig mal eigentlich nur auf das Signal warten, jetzt mal zuzulangen. Und in deren Sicht glaube ich wird diese Scott Galloway, Profozang würde ich nicht sagen, aber seine Erwartungen wahr werden. Wir werden das erleben, was wir schon bei Über erlebt haben, dass nämlich das Unternehmen tatsächlich dann von seinem Gründer getrennt wird. Mark Zuckerberg sitzt immer noch mega fest im Sattel, sowohl über die Eigentumsrechte als über alle Stimmrechte und so. Aber das kann so glaube ich nicht mehr lange gut gehen. Irgendwas muss da jetzt passieren. Und weiterhin der Welt so Facebook auszuliefern oder Facebook uns weiter so auszuliefern in dem Zustand, in dem es gerade ist, machen nicht mehr viele mit. Und vielleicht gibt es auch viele, die die kurze sechs Stunden Chance für ein Krisenexperiment gemacht haben, um mal nachzuarbeiten, wie hoch die Produktivitätsgewinne jetzt tatsächlich waren. Denn Menschen wurden mal nicht abgelenkt von ihrer Arbeit. Das sind wahnsinnige Effekte, die man schon sieht, wie viele Leute plötzlich auf alte SMS oder Telefonanrufe zurückgriffen und so. Und naja, mal sehen. Es ist einfach so eine längerwertige Geschichte, die da so läuft.
Aber ich vermute auch nicht, dass jetzt in den nächsten fünf Monaten Facebook zerschlagen wird.
Aber die Amtszeit Bidens wird da auf jeden Fall was verändern. Die dauert ja noch eine Weile.
Na ja, dann streicht der Staat seine Samthandschuhe ab. Du hast Lothardyke gelesen. Stellst du uns das heute vor?
Ich habe ihn nicht nur gelesen, ich habe ihn inhaliert. Ist noch zu leicht. Das war wirklich ein Spektakel. Also ich war am Wochenende viel mit der größeren Familie unterwegs und habe mich dann selber doch immer wieder erwischt, wie ich so meinen E-Reader mit auf dem Tisch liegen hatte, während die Familie irgendwelche Gespräche führte und ich dann doch lieber nochmal nachlas, was Slotadejk vor einem Jahr zu irgendwas gesagt hat. Und Satan habe ich mich so unterhalten von einem Buch geführt. Vielleicht kann ich ein Zitat gleich jetzt schon mal bringen, denn das passt auch ganz wunderbar zu unserem Salon. Slotadejk sagt so mittendrin in einem dieser Gespräche, ein guter Autor muss dem Leser die Energie liefern, mit der er durch das Buch gezogen wird. Wenn ein Verfasser nur seine anstrengende Seite präsentiert, dann wird Lektüre eigentlich zur Psychotherapie. Man müsste fürs Lesen bezahlt werden. Nun könnte man sagen, man ist das nicht Slotadejk selbst, der immer viel zu angestrengt uns seine Gedanken in Seiten zeigt und dann müssen wir irgendwie hunderte Seiten zorn und Zeit lesen und verstehen immer noch nicht, was er will. Und diesmal ist es ja ein Gesprächsband. Also er selber in Talk-Modus. Er reagiert auf Fragen und so weiter. Und es ist wirklich ein super entspanntes Lesen, wie man es nicht kennt von Slotadejk und trotzdem wahnsinnig reichhaltig. Also es ist wirklich unglaublich. Eine wirklich spektakuläre Lektüre, die ich auch im Salon gleich erst als allerletzten Text zum Ausklang. Denn wir lernen noch mal vieles Neues über Trump, über Influencer. Ganz neue Grundbegriffe werden gelegt. Die Menschheit wird noch mal in eine ganz neue, wie soll man sagen, in einen ganz neuen Zustand versetzt von ihm. Er stellt Forderungen, wie wir jetzt was wir aus Corona lernen für die Klimakrise und so. Also es ist wirklich ein Update der Menschheit wird eigentlich drin vorgeschlagen, würde ich sagen.
Hochinteressant. Und er ist ein Formulierungskünstler, wenn er Interviews gibt und auch in seinen Büchern, die man auch zum Teil so lesen kann wie Romane, also die schrecklichen Kinder der Neuzeit beispielsweise. Das kann man auch wie einen Roman rezipieren. Ja, ich habe etwas so schön Formuliertes wahrscheinlich nicht, aber trotzdem interessantes. Und zwar will ich einen Text vorstellen aus den Blättern, den Herfried Münkler geschrieben hat über eine Weltordnung ohne Hüter. Dann soll es aber auch um China im Jahr 2049 gehen. Auch da gibt es mal so eine Überlegung. Was wäre dann dann eigentlich? Droht uns dann der Krieg oder hat er schon stattgefunden? Nee, könnte was ganz anderes dann für die Chinesen wichtig sein. Dann, wie schon angekündigt, gibt es von mir Jacqueline Rose, die über Freud, den Todesstrieb und die spanische Krippe einen Vortrag gehalten hat und das natürlich mit unserer Pandemie verbindet. Dann gibt es ein vollkommen kurioses Interview. Also so kurios, dass ich nachgeprüft habe, ob es den Interviewpartner wirklich gibt oder ob die sich das ausgedacht haben. Und zwar ein Investmentbanker gibt einer sozialistischen Zeitung ein Interview. Und das ist sehr sehr erhellend und beeindruckend. Und dann noch als kleiner Rausschmeißer eine vollkommen idiotische Idee, eine Luxusjacht, mit der man aber auch das Klima retten kann.
Sehr gut, klingt interessant. Absolut Luxusjacht. Also Containerschifffahrt hatte ich ja schon angekündigt. Wir holen uns noch mal ein Update von Mark Milley, der war jetzt auch noch mal vom Kongress. Und er tauchte ja in einem Bob Woodward-Buch, das wir nicht lesen, weil wir sind schon mal auf Bob Woodward reingefallen. 300 Seiten irgendwas. Und eine Seite Trump-Zitate, die er vorher ausgekoppelt hat als Teaser für das Buch. Diesen Fehler machen wir nicht noch mal. Diese eine Seite kann man auch so in der New York Times lesen. Und auch noch mal ein kleiner Text zu Facebook. Ich habe so viele Notizen, dass wir gleich mal gucken, dass wir die Stunde nicht sprengen, die wir ansonsten so nennen.
Ja, ich habe auch sehr, sehr viele Notizen. Aber wir werden da einen Weg durchfinden. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr lesenswertes Buch.
Ja, es ist einfach spektakulär. Gut, dann sehen wir uns gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.